you guys have such a cool job it's
amazing what we're going to do with uid
is we're going to measure shapes of over
a billion galaxies and to do a
statistical study and so it's really
these new telescopes uclid and then
Roman in a few years are going to
provide huge amounts of data huge
amounts of measurements on Galaxies that
allow us to discern the properties of
dark matter and dark energy through
statistical studies if it's a billion
galaxies you got AI helping you in there
somewhere we have to have ai helping us
because we don't have enough grad
students to look at each Galaxy
individually over time God you guys have
such a cool job it's
amazing